what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I am currently all hopped up on
a combination of cold medicine like like
drowsy cold medicine and mucinex because
I have a cold so I have no idea what's
gonna come out of my mouth over the
course of the next 10 to 15 minutes
there's a really good chance I won't
remember it come morning men is gonna be
an adventure now for a long time we have
not done the video series what if based
on the Marvel Comics line what if the
what if Marvel comics line was basically
like what if like this happened instead
of that happening like what if Marvel
hadn't pissed everybody off after Secret
Wars like what if a spider-man had
stay'd venom what if Disney bought Fox
for fifty two billion dollars what if
things happen differently than the way
that were used to you what if Hugh
Jackman decided to come back as
Wolverine but I figured we would bring
this back and if we're going to do this
then we're gonna do a video on the
juggernaut becoming the flash because I
told you guys I would do it at one point
and I haven't done it in forever so what
we're gonna be doing here is we're not
really gonna be asking the question what
if juggernaut took up the mantle of the
flash because that does not sound cool
what we're gonna be doing is we're gonna
be answering the question what would
happen if the juggernaut were able to
tap into the Speed Force thereby gaining
the powers of the flash so in order to
answer that question we have to first
look at two things juggernaut scours as
they exist in Marvel Comics and what the
Speed Force is as well as what powers it
grants to those who can tap into it
after we do that we can discuss what
would likely happen if this actually did
occur first though we're going to look
at the juggernaut so close you guys
don't know juggernaut is the alter-ego
of Cain Marko who is the stepbrother of
Professor X also known as Charles Xavier
I don't know why you wouldn't know that
while serving in the Korean War
Marko finds a ruby inside an ancient
temple inscribed on the ruby are the
words whosoever touches this gym shall
be granted the power of the crimson gem
of cyttorak henceforth you who read
these words shall become forevermore a
human juggernaut so what the gem of
cyttorak
actually does is transform those who
touch it into the avatar of the
multi-dimensional you of Han dimensional
demon sit Iraq meaning that juggernaut
is able to channel those powers which
are quite immense now after what
juggernauts powers actually are he
possesses near immeasurable strength
he's among the strongest non cosmic
characters and Marvel Comics and we know
this because we've seen
go up against characters black Colossus
the thing Thor King Hyperion which is
basically Marvel super vamp and even
world war hulk and matched them
blow-for-blow in addition to his
strength juggernaut possesses seemingly
limitless durability which is bolstered
even more by his ability to channel the
gyms energy into a force field that
basically renders him immune from any
attack Jever not has been able to
survive powerful attacks from people
like Thor with his God blast cyclopses
optic blast and even several punches
from The Incredible Hulk juggernaut is
also able to heal insanely quickly from
80 damage he suffers survive without
food water or air and does not grow
tired from physical activity something
that is not true for me so because of
all these factors as well as his
heightened speed juggernaut is able to
build up a great deal of momentum once
he's in motion and frequently just like
charges at his opponents as his primary
means of attack he just runs after you
but once he's in motion and builds up
sufficient momentum Jever not is pretty
much impossible to stop although
opponents with sufficient strength have
been able to redirect that direction of
his movement now the only exception like
you think of of somebody who is not
basically a god more or less being able
to stop the juggernaut was when the
Incredible Hulk did it when he was
basically one of the Horsemen of
apocalypse the Incredible Hulk had his
powers augmented by celestial technology
it was not just basic Incredible Hulk so
the question that we're trying to figure
out here is what would happen if
juggernaut was somehow able to tap into
the Speed Force well to answer that we
first have to explain what the Speed
Force is the speed force is a concept
within DC Comics that was created during
the lightning strike that gave Barry
Allen his SuperSpeed now as Barry runs
he generates the Speed Force and it has
expanded to exist throughout the entire
DC multiverse as this kind of kinetic
wall of positively charged energy now
all the speedsters within the DC
Universe can access the Speed Force and
when one of them dies they sort of
merged with it and from the Speed Force
they derive a multitude of powers and
abilities now the primary and most
obvious of these powers that the various
speedsters derived specifically Barry
Allen is the weird run of Ezra Miller
from Justice League I know I'm not the
only one who noticed it I know a lot of
you guys are just like dude man do this
call medicine is kicking it I don't a
lot of guys are like man do this man
does that guy runs weird
and he does how does a flash run weird
the guy's job is to run you think the
flash would have like the perfect form
when it comes to running not only am i
impressed that he's the fastest person
alive but just look at how he runs
gracefully he doesn't run like a goof
like he does in Justice League man it's
it's so weird anyway obviously the
primary powers is superhuman speed which
also includes superhuman reflexes
agility cognition stamina and even
healing now the Flash's super speed is
well documented at DC colleagues as he's
performed several feats that indicate
that his speed is practically limitless
as an example of just how fast the flash
is during the final crisis event he's
able to outrun the black racer which is
an aspect of the Speed Force that serves
as the entity of death for speedsters
who seeks to return them to the Speed
Force which resulted in Barry Allen
basically having outran death for about
twenty years nothing else made sense of
that story but that did it's also been
repeatedly established that the flash
can travel much faster than the speed of
light and has even being able to run so
fast that he can manipulate time as we
see in the flashpoint event when he
traveled back in time to stop the murder
of his mother and then traveled back in
time again to let her die which resulted
in three different universes merging in
the one sound confusing it is near
limitless speed is not the only power
afforded by the Speed Force however
Barry Allen has demonstrated the ability
to vibrate the molecules of his body at
high enough frequency that he can pass
through solid objects and even
dimensional barriers he's able to rotate
his arms at a high enough speed to
produce cyclones and could throw arcs of
lightning at his enemies another
incarnation of the flash Wally West also
performed a feat known as the infinite
mass punch now the infinite mass punch
is possible where the flash is running
at a speed close to the speed of light
which causes him to gain a mass relative
to that speed and allows him to deliver
a devastating punch now as to the actual
force of it it was described by writer
Grant Morrison as being equivalent to
the power of a white dwarf star I have
no idea how much power that is so what
would happen if juggernaut was able to
tap into the Speed Force I think we need
to start with figuring out how that
would happen in the first place
so in the case of both Barry Allen and
Wally West they became speedsters when
lightning struck a cabinet full of
chemicals that they were standing next
to causing them both to be doused in the
chemicals and then of course
gave access to the speedforce no I don't
know why juggernaut would be standing
next to a cabinet full of chemicals he's
kind of a stupid guy so it's not like
he'd be engaging in science or something
like that you know it's like he's like
hey I'm just standing next to this wall
of chemicals for science it's not like
it wouldn't work that way with
juggernaut you know he's just he's kind
of a dumb guy but for the sake of this
story we're gonna assume that he is for
whatever reason you don't put the reason
down in the comment section I want to
know why you guys think juggernaut is
standing next to a wall full of
chemicals I have no idea why I'm asking
you to do that but I think it'd be funny
to see some of the replies that you guys
have but regardless we're just gonna go
with that whole thing so our story would
begin with the middle of a battle with
like the juggernaut and the x-men of
course this battle goes down as it
usually does with juggernaut getting the
upper hand
initially the x-men fighting back
and holding their own then all of a
sudden a strange portal opens the sky
and like a single bolt of lightning just
like escapes through it and hits the
juggernaut before the portal closes now
before anyone can process what just
happened juggernaut just takes off from
the battle much to the surprise of the
x-men now from there we cut to a scene
of the Justice League meeting in the
watchtower with Batman explained that it
appears that during a recent battle
between the flash and the reverse-flash
a whole was ripped in the barrier that
separated the DC Multiverse
from another unknown and unexplored
universe where the question is asked how
Batman knew this Batman just kind of
shrugs and says I don't know the writers
said I do because I'm Batman and I can
do anything now flash then states that
he feels like his connection to the
Speed Force has been weaker ever since
his fight with the reverse-flash as if a
piece of the Speed Force was missing so
the Justice League decides they're gonna
have to find a way to reopen the portal
so they could go to the unknown universe
and set everything right because they
believe that the Speed Force has been
introduced to the universe and falls
into the wrong hands the results could
be catastrophic now as we cut back to
the marvel universe we see juggernaut
streaking across a remote stretch of
desert testing at his new powers how
many dude he's haulin he's just bracing
man he's like like a big dust trail
behind him it'd be kind of cool but he
delivers a classic supervillain
monologue that lets us know exactly what
it is that he's thinking you know the
more I think about the juggernaut
streaking across the desert there could
be like a meme about that right you know
like what she calls us says she's home
alone and like the juggernaut she's
raced it across the desert is like a
stream of sand up in the air behind I
think it'd be hilarious somebody needs
to make that do
take that and tweet it to me and I will
tweet that back out like I will retweet
that that'll be hilarious but with these
newfound powers there's no way the ex
buddy can stop him and he finally
accomplishes his ultimate goal you know
he has the intention anyway of
accomplishing his ultimate goal of
defeating the x-men once and for all
which I guess is actually juggernauts
ultimate goal it's kind of funny and
Marvel Comics the only real motivation
the juggernaut has you know for being
the juggernaut is to try to destroy
Charles Xavier and that's really about
it he's a pretty simple villain didn't
really have a whole lot of motivations
and schemes outside of that but
basically that's what the juggernaut
sets out to do you know he goes all the
way back to Westchester and attacks the
Xavier school now at first the x-men
really think nothing of this I mean
they'll just go out they'll meet the
juggernaut you know and they'll
basically battle him and it'll just be
another fight with the juggernaut
this'll eventually win but they soon
realized that this is not the same
juggernaut that they fought in the past
Colossus who's been able to stand toe to
toe with juggernaut in the past is
unable to land a single punch
due to juggernaut super speed now sports
desperate for help Professor X sends out
a telepathic message to Quicksilver
asking him for help but when Quicksilver
arrives it becomes clear that he's
unable to keep up with the juggernaut
something that makes sense which is why
I don't understand the videos where
people ask the question who's faster
flash or Quicksilver why is that a
question
it's like asking what's harder steel or
wood you can Google Marvel's version of
the flash and you'll come up with like
seven people who are faster than
Quicksilver but from here juggernaut
just lays waste to the x-men I mean dude
it's ridiculous man juggernaut laid
waste to the x-men with the Flash's
powers they would just get wrecked
it would even seem fair but when all
hope is lost the same portal that had
opened earlier
opens again and we see the Justice
League appear in the Marvel Universe now
as soon as they do
juggernaut charges at him and
immediately the flash can tell the
juggernaut is a possession of the Speed
Force the flash engages juggernaut in
battle and leads him away from the
mansion so the rest of the league can
survey the damage now this of course
leads to a conversation between the
Justice League and Professor X who
explains that juggernaut has a
vulnerability to psychic attacks but
that they couldn't export it because
they have to remove his helmet which
they couldn't do now of course at first
Xavier tries to send a message to the
flash to attempt to remove the helmet of
the juggernaut now flash gives it his
best shot but while he is as fast as the
juggernaut he's not nearly as strong and
so of course the fight between this two
starts to get out of hand now still late
to Professor X through his telepathy the
flash receives a message to return to
Westchester which he complies with
somebody every bit of his connection to
the Speed Force to try to put some
distance between himself and the
juggernaut now once they arrive a new
plan devised by the Justice League and
Professor X is revealed as Superman
delivers a powerful punch to juggernauts
helmet nearly knocking it off following
this we see a pretty epic battle between
juggernaut and the combined effort of
Superman and the flash with flash using
a speed to maneuver juggernaut into
Superman's punches until his helmet
comes off which leads to Professor X
launching a telepathic attack to
basically shut down juggernauts mind
temporarily
now with juggernaut incapacitated the
story starts to wind down flash uses one
of his other abilities which basically
grants him the ability to steal the
speed of others or their leader kinetic
energy more or less but he basically
uses it to strip the juggernaut of his
access to the Speed Force after this the
Justice League returns to their universe
thanks to some gadget Batman's invented
most likely because it's Batman it was
probably in his utility belt the whole
time we of course cut to juggernaut
waking up from his trance in the middle
of the desert only to find out that he
no longer has any connection to the
Speed Force and therefore his speed
powers are pretty much gone which of
course causes him to scream though you
know I Dorothy a derp at the end of The
Revenge of the Sith which is one of the
dumbest image to a movie ever George
Lucas I'm so glad Disney bought those
rights from you because all you were
ever gonna do is screw it up even more
so while juggernaut and the Speed Force
would be insanely powerful because of
his immense strength and speed as I
stated earlier the what if college were
almost always one shot so we needed a
resolution to the problem that would
result in the good guys basically
winning by the end of the issue and I
think that this is the most likely
scenario for that to happen you know
could have caused an insane amount of
damage across the face of the world
absolutely you probably could have
killed all the superheroes but as we've
talked about earlier that's never really
been juggernaut submission he basically
just wants to take out the x-men and
that's really about it so I didn't
really feel like putting the ending to a
story where Joker that kills everybody
in the Marvel Universe but if you do
want to see it post a comment down below
and I will have my writer Ryan get to
work on that and will basically do flash
you know juggernaut with the powers of
the flash kills the Marvel Universe
anyway guys uh we're gonna go ahead and
ring this video to an end if you
new here to come as explained make sure
you guys said the sub button to become
part of the Rob coy if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a light
and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]